welcome to designing in the browser in
this series we explore how to take a
design build it and then tweak it in the
browser using the latest in web
technology and design systems today
we're going to take a look at how we can
extend the capabilities of a nil CSS
with pre and post processors in many
design systems like material design we
use sass as a preprocessor to give us a
ton of power and control over our code
as well as the post process of post CSS
to make sure it works cross browser
there are a lot of benefits and
different ways to do this so let's dive
in so why would you need to extend CSS
it gives us so much styling power
there's a bit more that we may need in
order to tailor CSS to our own needs
especially with design systems a big
reason for using CSS processing tools is
easier maintenance and browser support
for example we now have dynamic
variables with CSS custom properties but
we didn't have that capability a few
years ago and older browsers like
Internet Explorer 11 don't support some
of these newer features like custom
properties with a preprocessor we can
store these variables as static values
meaning they can work across browser
will often see pre and post processors
being used in large design systems and
projects material design Google's open
source UI design system uses sass as a
preprocessor and post CSS as a post
processor if you're not familiar with
material design check out material for
more information and for resources on
the web platform using sass allows for
material to create an API for our design
system and specify what you can do to
extend the system while still
maintaining its integrity
for example material includes mix-ins
like MDC button ink color you may be
thinking why use a sass mixin instead of
just writing color and the color that
you want there the reason why is because
the output of the mixin looks like this
we need to keep various states in mind
without overriding each other's styles
and a way to do that is with an explicit
API here's another example this would
output to this so you can see that while
it seems like changing the field outline
color through a mixin isn't really doing
that much it really is
three different classes and various
pieces of that element are updated
through that single line of code this
actually gets more complex with some of
our components as their API is become
more complex here's an example of a
masonry image list where one of the
mix-ins involved specifies how many
columns to include and what the spacing
should be between each image in that
list within the columns so the code for
that becomes this it affects not only
the element itself but also child
elements to make sure that the spacing
is correct that only horizontally but
also vertically this image list is one
place where we can really see the
benefits of using sass in our UIs in
this example as we resize this image
list to be smaller the number of columns
and the spacing between those columns
decreases as the size of the screen gets
smaller and vice versa increases as size
the screen gets bigger and so this is a
part of that styling API if we look at
the code here what we're doing is we're
starting at the baseline we're starting
at that mobile view with the columns
being 1 and the spacing between those
being 0 as you start to get bigger for
example at a screen of 500 pixels or
larger we're now going to be at two
columns with 8 pixels between those
items we're getting a little bigger at
800 pixels it goes to 3 right here you
can see that as being included as a
mixin called MDC image list masonry
columns and we using the same mixin
throughout - then a thousand pixels
provide for cross and at 1200 pixels
provide the five across so here with
just a couple of lines of code were
chained in the entire layout this
responsiveness is included as a part of
the styling API for our components as I
mentioned earlier MDC web also uses post
processing for our CSS those popular
technology to do this is called post CSS
we use post CSS to make our CSS
backwards compatible for older browsers
an example of this is adding prefixes to
certain properties like column count
which we just saw in the image list
with autoprefixer as a part of post CSS
we don't need to memorize which
properties do and don't need a prefix as
we extend our CSS styles and so what
that looks like without the processing
is this and then when it processes
applying those prefixes it becomes this
soon CSS will give us the ability to
natively extend it and do all sorts of
things with the technology called CSS
Houdini with this technology developers
now have access to the CSS object model
for the very first time Houdini is a
series of browser API so that allows
developers to tell the browser how they
want it to read and render CSS along
with a slew of other performance boosts
and really great benefits the current
API is for Houdini include the layout
API the paint API properties and values
API animation worklet and the type
object model ll talk about custom
properties API in another show but for
now I want to show you the power of the
paint API and how you can use it today
to extend a system like material in a
progressively enhanced way so in order
to do this I quickly want to talk to you
about shape within material theming
material includes shape as a core part
of its theming subsystem shape is an
integral part of an application style
language because it can be used to
indicate state it can also bring in the
user's focus to a specific area like a
menu bar or an action item the floating
action button for example is round and
lives in the bottom of the webpage
permanently as a consistent action
source the round shape contrasts the web
page as most elements in a web page are
rectangular in shape to help you
determine the shape for the look and
feel of your application material
provides a tool called a material shape
tool you can find this on material that
I oh and go to the shape sub section
underneath material foundation so this
shape customization tool allows us to
explore the different types of
components and what they look like with
various shapes the first are small
components these are things like buttons
so you can apply various rounded shapes
to the button we even have angled
corners as a shape option which is a cut
corner
on each of those edges also medium
components you could play around it so
here we have things like dialogues and
cards and then larger components are
things like your menu so you can have
those we've rounded and bubbly or have
them be more straight across art angular
and angular you'll notice that in this
tool we have two corners shapes rounded
and angles while on the web angled
corners are not currently possible as a
part of today's browsers this is a
system that spans platforms and angled
corners are possible on Android flutter
and iOS
angled corners have been discussed by
web standards since 2012 but we have yet
to see them implemented in browsers
however with CSS Houdini nearly anything
is possible
so I made a little dough to show you how
we can have angled edges on the web
today so in this example here I'm just
going to zoom in we have these material
buttons and we have these adjusted
buttons now they have the ripple and
everything applied to them when you
click so you can see that they're the
exact same sort of interactions here we
even have this button popping out for
that rainiest material button but these
buns on the bottom had that angled shape
so the way that I did this was with a
worklet let's get into that
okay so first to understand the
requirements of this demo let's go over
the types of material design buttons the
first button is a standard button that
just goes on the backgrounds and when
you hover over it you can see a subtle
outline of that button and when you
click on it you see it a little bit more
pronounced then there is the outlined
button the outline button has an outline
around the button which matches the
color of the text within the button the
fields button has a background behind
the button and then there is a raised
button which has a drop shadow
underneath the button which extends as
you click it or as you hover over the
button so we needed to make all of these
work we need to fill all these use cases
we also need to make sure that this
ripple effect is still working and does
not extend our element so when I made
these angled corners the first thing I
thought about was using a mask because
when we mask an element we are
preventing anything from going out
that elements so here we have a mask set
which is using this angled corners
worklets and it's using the filled mode
so I've used a custom identifier as an
argument inside of this paint worklet so
here I can mask all of these buttons all
of these buttons that have the angled
clasp applied to them and then for the
outline buttons I'm specifying this
outline mode I'm using the exact same
worklet but I'm using it as a border
image so here I'm painting it as a
border image as well as using it on mask
on the same exact element so it's pretty
dynamic what you can do with these
custom properties if you want to take a
look at what that code looks like here I
have a few input properties those improv
properties are corner radius the stroke
weight and the paint color so we can
adjust the radius of those buttons the
custom identifiers as the input argument
for the mode the fills our outline mode
and then I'm going through I am looking
at every single corner and I'm adjusting
those corners based on the inputs so I
can make these corners uniform or I can
change what those radiuses are so here I
have 12 pixels and 0 0 0 but what if I
want to make this like 20 and then 0 and
then 20 and then 0 you can see it's
starting to paint in so I have the
ability to every single corner adjust
the angles I have the ability to specify
the type of transformation I want here
whether that be a rounded button because
we can just Denton CSS whether that be
an angled button Houdini gives us the
power to do that and I can specify how
I'm using that worklet so I can use it
as an outline I can use it as a
backgrounds I can use it as both in the
example of the outline button that's
exactly what I'm doing
with the raised button I did have to
adjust the HTML markup a little bit to
give it a shadow container because of
what WebKit mask does which is prevent
anything from living outside of that
mask which was needed for the ripple so
I did add a little bit of markup here
for the shadow container but you get the
same effect with the MDC button by
applying the same kind of
transformations on that shadow container
if you want to explore this demo a
little bit more we will link this in the
show notes it is free for you to explore
it's free for you to use is free for you
to build upon it's a really interesting
upcoming technology that will provide us
so much from power with CSS so I'm
really excited for it and I hope that
you are too CSS is such a powerful tool
and we can leverage its powers to have
even more control when we use extension
tools such as post processors
preprocessors and Houdini what do you
use for your styling setup leave a
comment down below and we'll see you
next time
say bye just go
[Music]